multi-platinum la rocker's motley crew
rose to fame with their
debauchery-fueled brand of heavy metal
that enthralled readers around the world
with the dirt
a hit memoir that made its way to
netflix in 2019. here's all the dirt
behind the dirt
on the page and on the screen compared
to other rock biography books the dirt
just has a lot
more it's got more stories of illegal
activity and heavy metal debauchery
and it's also got a lot of authors five
guys are credited on the cover
motley crew band members vince neil
nikki sixx mick mars and tommy lee
along with neil strauss he's the guy who
did all the interviewing and assembled a
coherent narrative
out of what must have been stacks of
tapes and copious notes culled from
following around four guys for months
strauss first hooked up with motley crue
in 1998 when he briefly toured with the
band for a profile and spin
at the time he was finalizing his
marilyn manson book
the long hard road out of hell and the
crew members who read it loved it
when publisher harper collins contracted
the group for a book later on
they immediately asked strauss to helm
the project once more he went on tour
with motley crew and visited each
musician at home
probably the hardest part for him to
write vince neal's account of his
four-year-old daughter's ultimately
tragic battle with cancer
strauss told mtv he was crying i was
crying it tore me apart
when i gave him the book i said you
might not want to read this
the dirt manages to top most every other
rock biography with its sheer volume of
nauseating and unbelievably tall tales
while hammer of the gods breathlessly
describes every despicable and
disgusting act ever committed by the
members of led zeppelin
it can't compare with vince neil's egg
burrito story from the dirt
the motley crue singer discusses the
band's good old days it's early years as
a band playing la's rainbow club by
night and using drummer tommy lee's
chevy van as a party truck later at
night
so this is the party truck huh
you found it said vince neil after the
rainbow each night we'd walk to santa
monica boulevard where all the young
rockers and actors who never made it
were pimping themselves
and then even if they had girlfriends at
the time they'd entertain any girls who
wanted to get into tommy's van
afterwards the crew would scrounge up
enough money to buy a breakfast burrito
from a local establishment
then each member of the band would place
their genitals quote
into the warm meat to cover up the smell
of the women who had been there earlier
why in their words so that our
girlfriends didn't know how
that makes sense uh kinda
while the dirt reveals one brazen
display of caligula-like excess after
another
the book goes a bit beyond the drug
taking in exploits for instance
in the mid-1980s the band's reps sought
to protect its investment
and made every member of the drink and
drug adult group get clean
guitarist mcmars recounted our
management was trying to do some kind of
extensive plastic surgery on the band
and we had to see all these doctors who
would try to brainwash us into behaving
differently once a week we'd have to go
to relationship counseling like an old
bitter married couple
there we'd learn how to talk to each
other instead of fighting or we'd
discuss our feelings and whatever was
going on that week
mars resented all of that especially
since he'd kicked his habits without any
formal help but it was the waterworks
that really irked him
he said every therapist wanted us to let
loose and cry and i
hate crybabies i became so sick of
seeing everyone in the band bawling
their eyes out
you want to know what rehab was really
like
feelings and crying and apologies
december 8
1984 looms dark in rock history that's
when an intoxicated vince neil drove
himself and hanoi rock strummer nicholas
razzle dingley to a liquor store to get
more booze for a multi-day party
neil lost control on a winding road and
smashed into another car
instantly killing his passenger the dirt
tells this horrific story but it also
reveals that a few hours before that
tragedy
another sad and shocking event nearly
befell the group
neil says that he woke up that afternoon
to see something on the beach which he
described as a small black whale
upon examination it was mick mars passed
out in the sand in black leather from
head to toe
what did neil do nothing neil wrote he
mumbled something about just wanting to
be left lying there so i left him there
looking like e.t when he was sick after
dark mars regained consciousness but he
was sure he was dead and was now a ghost
and instinctively headed toward a glow
of light coming from the distance
it was neal's house where the party had
turned sad and silent
mars explained i figured that they were
crying for me that i had drowned in the
water and they had discovered my body
according to band manager doug thaler in
the dirt vince neil's self-sabotaging
behavior in the early 90s
threatened his position in motley crew
by february 1992
basis nikki sixx was over it during a
major rainstorm that flooded large parts
of la
each member made the treacherous journey
to the studio but not
neil after waiting for neal for hours
the band's tour manager faxed the singer
telling him to show up
asap neil then called explaining that he
hadn't done so already because the phone
lines were down
according to six by the time he arrived
the seed was already planted in our
minds that he was holding us back
neal finally arrived soaked and sulking
six casually mentioned that the band was
considering new lead singer talks while
neil retorted that the reason he'd
skipped rehearsals
was because he thought the album was
dumb after more bickering neil left in a
huff
six wrote he says he was fired i say he
quit
after the huge sales of the 1989 album
dr feelgood
electra records was eager to stay in the
motley crew business
and in 1991 gave the band a 25 million
dollar contract but the band's future
remained shaky
with neil gone the group recruited
singer john karabi
according to thaler the record the new
crew recorded took up 14 months and 2
million dollars in studio costs
all that for a relative dud released in
march 1994
motley crue debuted at number seven on
the billboard 200
then the album fell to 28 in its second
week the supporting tour was a similar
disaster
nikki 6 recalled that at the first stop
in tucson arizona
only 4 000 tickets had been sold for a
15 000 seat amphitheater
he tried to give tickets away at a radio
station and only two people showed up
what happened rock drastically changed
between dr feelgood and 1994.
the la hair metal sound was out grunge
and alternative rock were in
motley crew was old news in the 90s with
the low sales of motley crue surpassed
by even lower sales of its 1997
follow-up the vinsnil reunion record
generation swine
there was nowhere to go but up and
rather than chase trends motley crew
embraced what fans wanted them to be
degenerate party monsters and they did
it not with an album
or tour or even a reality show they did
it with the dirt
not only did literate music fans come to
expect a certain amount of sordid detail
and rock memoirs in the wake of the dirt
but it spawned a cottage industry in
motley crew books
the success of the dirt inspired tommy
lee and vince neil to go
solo with their own individual memoirs
tommyland and tattoos and tequila
respectively
while nikki sixx cleaned up the journals
he wrote during the depths of his drug
addiction to create the heroine diaries
musicians take inspiration from wherever
they can nikki 6
always motley crew's most dominant and
prolific songwriter took that idea to
heart
even if things got a little too
inceptiony along the way
the dirt dredged up so many memories for
six and his bandmates
some bad mostly good that they got back
together with departed drummer tommy lee
to record a brand new album with the
original lineup for the first time in
more than a decade
that record 2008 saints of los angeles
and while many motley crew songs are
based on
actual experiences in six's life saints
is loosely based on the dirt
in other words it's the musical version
of a book that's about
himself and the other members of motley
crew in fact the lp was almost
actually named the dirt that makes any
sense
probably doesn't but that's because i'm
half nuts anyway so it's okay
the dirt first thrilled readers and
rocked its way to the new york times
best seller list back in 2001
and the film version didn't make its
netflix debut until 2019
that's a long time between source
material and adaptation
but it's not because nobody was trying a
film version of the dirt could have hit
movie screens in late 2006 or early 2007
that's when paramount classics forged an
agreement to make the movie with mtv
films
things got as far as a table read of the
script in 2014 but then focus features
brought the project back from the dead
in 2015 with jackass veteran jeff
tremaine already attached as a director
even once netflix acquired the rights to
the movie version of the dirt it took a
full two years to get the thing finished
playing a rock star must be fun for
actors they get to live out their
wildest rock star fantasies and awards
consideration is often part of the
conversation
in the past two decades a number of
acclaimed actors have won oscars for
portraying real-life musical icons but
when the dirt finally got made
filmmakers went with a cast made up
largely of performers who aren't quite
household names
such as game of thrones star ooh and
rayon as mick mars
and douglas booth as nikki sixx over the
years a number of much bigger stars were
pursued or attached to the project
in 2007 vince neil announced that the
opening of his las vegas tattoo parlor
that the legendary christopher walken
had signed on to play the legendary ozzy
osbourne
while val kilmer was a go for cameo as
david lee roth none of those choices
worked out obviously
in both the book and film adaptations of
the dirt cheating death is a major
recurring theme
vince neal walked away from a drunk
driving accident that killed his
passenger
mick mars thought he died on a beach one
day and nikki sixx recalled the time he
actually was dead for a few minutes
it would seem that the theme extended to
the making of the film adaptation of the
dirt during production
in new orleans in march 2018 a member of
the film's crew was de-rigging a set
when one of the electrical components
delivered a nasty shock
a rep for the film told the hollywood
reporter even though all of our safety
protocols were in place
an accident did occur and a crew member
was injured by electricity
filming wasn't interrupted because the
cast was off shooting somewhere else
while this ill-fated d-rigger was
tearing down a set that was no longer
needed
emts took him to a nearby hospital where
he was listed in stable condition and
recovered
no word on who will be the next victim
of the curse of the crew but you should
probably stay far
far away from tommy lee just in case
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite musicians are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one